all right uh good morning
uh
um I guess we're uh I sort of feel like
we've we've we've scheduled a party and
uh a couple of the key key guests didn't
come but I guess maybe they'll uh
they'll arrive as we're going on anyway
good morning
um welcome to the house Judiciary
Committee my name is Bob Lin I'm the new
chair of the committee
um
and I want to uh speak to the the fellow
members of the committee first first of
all I want to congratulate you on your
election and tell you uh that I how much
I am looking forward to working with you
uh this year
I've circulated a contact form which
I've asked everyone to to fill out just
with with uh I know we I know that you
know our the staff has this but I'm if
there's if there's a better phone number
to reach you at or a better email
address I'd ask you to put that on the
form and then what I what I will do is I
will make copies of that and circulate
it to everybody so that we all have each
other's best phone number and email
address to contact each other if we need
if we need to do that
oh sorry no problem no problem
um
so what I'd like to do first and again
just this is I mean I know I know many
of you some obviously much better than
others but some of you I don't know and
I suspect that you may not know each
other particularly if you're if you're
new so um what I'd like to do uh
initially is just uh to ask everyone uh
to sort of go around the table ask
everyone to just sort of introduce
yourself
um who you are where you're from how
long you've been in the legislature
um why you chose Judiciary if you did
and maybe some of you didn't and that's
fine too uh
um what you hope to accomplish uh and I
I guess I would say not only on this
committee but if there are you know if
you have if there are important pieces
of legislation that that are going to be
before other committees that you think
are really important you've sponsored or
you have an interest in you tell us
about that also
um and then I the other the last thing
is any particular expertise that you
think you have that may be helpful to
the committee that might be something
that would be helpful uh uh to myself uh
and vice chair Wallace and the ranking
uh member Smith in term if we need to
assign subcommittees or something like
that it would be important to know
people that have particular interests or
particular expertise so uh maybe we
could start with representative
testerman
if you press the red if the red on the
right there you go okay
um and this is my fourth term at uh the
state house uh I've sat on the criminal
law committee for the first three uh I
am not a lawyer I'm actually an engineer
uh but I uh I've enjoyed this kind of
of uh things to study whether it be
judicial or or
criminal law uh
I've got no particular
I would say set in bonus or set in
opinions except that I do believe in the
Constitution uh and I don't believe that
it should be modified all right at least
modified without a formal procedure uh
so I I'm not here to judge make
judgments on it it either is or it isn't
uh I live in Franklin uh I'm we're a
single uh City there's two two
representatives from that City uh I'm
currently retired uh and uh that's
that's about most of what I have thank
you
thank you representative testerman
representative Staples
Walt Stapleton uh from Sullivan County
District Six uh representing Claremont
and Croydon
this is my um
third term in the house
last term I was in environment and
Agriculture and prior to that Health and
Human Services
was actually looking forward to go back
to health and human services but uh
ended up here
sometimes you can't control where your
parachute lands
um
but you know it's a new and exciting
experience
some of my particular interest and bills
initiatives
bail and detention reform that we've had
a problem with over the country since
2018 and reform and betterment of the
family court system
uh to give a more fair uh treatment to
people who come before the court
and there's been a lot of problems with
that in that area my background is
basically 56 years in the railroad
industry I worked for several railroads
in New Haven railroad the Erie Railroad
Short Line railroads
um and then I ran my own Consulting
business since 1986.
to 2017 and railroad Consulting and
marketing and sales operations and
government affairs
and also sold railroad casualty
and property insurance from 2001 on to
2017 retired my business 2017.
thank you representative
yeah hi uh Eric tour from Brentwood New
Hampshire which is just west of Exeter
for people who don't know that
um this is my first term serving uh very
pleased to be here
um
uh what my background is in
um uh Healthcare uh Public Health
Consulting
um basically to state and federal
programs and and Community organizations
focused on uh access to care for
underserved populations I've been doing
that for about 30 years and um uh I must
say I I assumed with that I might land
on the health and human services but I'm
very pleased to be here on this
committee I um and I still have to get
my head around the full scope of of what
the committee focuses on but you know
I've always been very interested in sort
of the the rights and human rights side
of things that uh that I know come
through the committee
um you know regarding reproduction
regarding regarding marriage regarding
um
some some of the other uh aspects I will
say my my wife's an obstetrician
gynecologist
um and uh also the interaction between
um sort of the social issues
um and the judicial system uh perhaps
around
um people with substance use disorders
and things along those lines
thank you representative
representative divine
good morning everyone I'm Shelley Devine
um I'm from Nashua board one Ward one
and
um my background is not in politics at
all not in not law any of this not the
judicial law or anything like that um uh
first timer
in the state house I am absolutely feel
like a freshman here so I'm here to
learn I'm also here to serve the people
of New Hampshire the best way that I can
I've been in the fitness industry for
over 10 years so I have a background in
health and a lot of coaching I coach
people individually
my concerns are obviously probably
women's rights Women's Health I'm also
interested in gun safety and protecting
um you know our children so that's
pretty much where I stand and very
excited to be here on this committee and
I hope I can just do a good job
thank you representative fine
representative Grisha
thank you Mr chair I'm representative
Jeff greeson this is my second term I
was on the Commerce Committee last term
so I evidently representative Lynn you
drew the Short Straw and you got me this
time I don't know not at all I am not an
attorney but I have watched uh every
episode of Perry Mason so I am well
versed on incompetent irrelevant and
immaterial and uh but otherwise I look
forward to it there's actually a a great
opportunity I'm willing to learn
anything
so thank you
representative Alexandria
um thank you Mr chair so my name is Joe
Alexander I represent the town of
Goffstown this is my third term on this
committee
um third term in general excited to come
back to this committee I really like the
policy that we talk about
um by trade I'm a full-time bartender so
if I leave early that means I got to go
to work and slings and beers
um but other than that I have a master's
in public policy at University of New
Hampshire so excited to get back to work
thank you great uh representative uh
where are we here uh Lambs
hi I'm uh Judy Lanza I was like say from
Goffstown as well and
um I'm uh let's say one of the first
Democrats that have gotten elected in a
while in Goffstown so I'm a labor and
delivery nurse and I've worked 39 years
as a nurse and I work currently at the
Elliott hospital as well as doing this
and I want to do a great job in um and
serve Goffstown as well as the state of
New Hampshire
so I'm new so that's the big thing I'm
willing to learn a lot and I'm ready to
take in
and also do whatever I can to do a great
job for everybody so thank you for your
time
thank you representative Lorenzo uh good
morning everyone I'm representative
Charlotte dilorenzo I am the deputy
ranking member of this committee I've
been on Judiciary this is going into my
for three terms and now again this term
so going into fourth term
um
my expertise is in housing particularly
rental housing I worked as a property
manager for 35 years
managing properties in most most of
Massachusetts but also in Maine in New
Hampshire
um I worked as a compliance director for
one of the companies that I work for
where I
um
where I was in charge of making sure
that all of our um policies procedures
were compliant with federal state and
local law
I also worked for a Pine Street Inn
which is New England swag just homeless
Service
Agency for 10 years the last 10 years of
my um work
work career and I learned about you know
homelessness
causes of homelessness and for me it was
probably the best job that I ever had I
didn't want to retire
um my educational background is
paralegal training I studied paralegal
training at the University of new new
University of Massachusetts Boston uh
where I got my VA degree and then I went
on to the paralegal program at Boston
University which was a postgraduate um
program
my interests are individual rights
um
those listed in a First Amendment of the
Constitution I am also interested in
social justice
I'm not an expert but I did
Prime sponsor the ombudsman's law the
right to know arguments but bunsman's
law
um and
the governor has hired a an ombudsman
and they're going to be rolling out that
program so the program
um basically
is
an alternative to going to Superior
Court when a person has a right to know
complaint and it's a faster cheaper
quicker way for citizens to be heard
so thank you all and I'm really happy to
be here thank you representative uh
Delorenzo uh representative gutoff
good morning I'm Caitlin kutab I'm from
Windham
I am a mom of four kids and my
background is in software engineering
I am happy to be here
um
this is my first term and what I hope to
accomplish is serving the people of New
Hampshire for the better I have an
interest
in kids because of my kids so in some of
the education aspects and I also have a
little bit of an interest in some of the
election laws and just being more
transparent
so that's what I hope to accomplish
thank you Mr chairman great thank you hi
um so uh my name is Bob Lin I'm also
from Windham I'm in my uh second term uh
first term is being chairman and I guess
what I would say is I have some
experience in the law but I don't have
any experience in being chairman of uh
of a house committee so I will I'm I'm
definitely in the learning mode myself
and I will be looking to all of you and
particularly to the ranking member and
to the uh the vice chair for assistance
and advice and guidance I'm more than
willing to to listen to any of you if
you have questions if you have questions
concerns whatever this is a learning
experience for me also I
I spent a long time as a judge on both a
trial judge and a appellate judge in New
Hampshire retired about three years ago
when I turned 70
um I I have uh two bills uh that I
believe actually three that I believe
will come before uh this committee one
is a proposed Constitutional Amendment
uh to raise the retirement age of Judges
from 70 to 75 that I introduced that
bill last year it did not go anywhere
I'm hoping that it'll have better fate
uh a better fate this year I also have a
bill uh uh that will come before this
committee to establish a superior court
land use docket where judges will be
appointed to that will sort of
specialize in that area and I think
that's one of the one of the ideas
behind that is to kind of streamline the
process of getting thing land use
decisions that are appealed to the
courts getting them heard more quickly
and more uh more efficiently so that's
another one and then I also have a
landlord tenant bill that
um
that again I think it actually I believe
last year it did pass the house but was
killed in the Senate it basically deals
with
there is what in my view and I've I
understand people may have different
views in this but in my view a
sort of crazy Supreme Court case from
the 1980s that basically says if you
have a leased for a year
of restricted property the term of the
lease doesn't matter it's uh you uh the
landlord cannot terminate the tenancy
simply because the lease is up if
there's no other reason to terminate it
that uh to me doesn't make much sense
there was a dissent by Justice Netto in
that case which I thought was a very
well reasoned descent so anyway I've
I've basically I have a bit has a have a
bill that would propose to overrule that
Supreme Court decision
um so I um I and I also am very
interested in bail somebody else here
mentioned bail I'm I'm very concerned
about bail issues I have a an issue on
bail
um that will go to criminal justice and
lastly
um
uh my my lifelong hobby has been uh
target shooting I'm very interested in
you know I'm a very Avid uh Firearms
owner I've I've a very strong proponent
of the Second Amendment and uh so I have
uh I you know that will be those kind of
issues are things that I will be uh
particularly focusing on even though
they may not come before this committee
uh so thank you
representative Smith thank you Mr chair
um I'm Marjorie Smith
this is my 13th term
people ask me why I keep on running and
I have a very easy answer I keep on
running until we get it right and we
haven't gotten it right yet uh and so
here I am
um those of you who are freshmen and are
understandably nervous I can tell you
that I learned something new every day
and sometimes I learned five new things
in a day
um so it's it's exciting and it's
challenging
um what I missed immediately on this
committee is our former clerk because he
knew how to adjust the chairs so they
were the right height right now I feel
that I'm sitting with my chin on the
table and it is very uncomfortable so if
any of you know how to adjust chairs
please see me afterwards
um I do oh thank goodness
um I too believe in um in the Second
Amendment
um
and my interpretation of the Second
Amendment might just differ a little
from um the chairs uh belief in the
Second Amendment but on many of those
issues I believe my position is
supported by the majority of the the
citizens of the state including gun
owners and that has to do with
responsible gun ownership
but that's not an issue that comes
before this committee that's just kind
of icing on the cake on the side
um I am a very firm believer in personal
privacy
and in the rights of individuals
uh and I realized how complicated these
issues are and when a bill comes in here
and you look at the title and you say oh
yes I'm with that a hundred percent
and then you read the text
and you find out that what you thought
this bill was about it isn't so so my
single advice to everybody on the
committee new and old is be open to
everything that comes here before the
committee
and redo your homework read the bills
talk to people who know about the issues
and wait a bit before you make your
judgment
um I have I have divided my time in
those 13 terms between this committee
and finance and when they say it's not
the money
it's always the money
I look forward to working with all of
you
good morning my name is Louise Andrus I
am from Salisbury I represent Merrimack
County District 5 Andover Danbury Hill
Salisbury and Webster this is my second
term but I feel like a freshman because
the first term was so much remote and
meetings are held everywhere but here
and when we got to come here it was like
a whole new experience so this year I do
I feel just like
I'm a freshman uh this is my second
year on judiciary
I'm not a lawyer my background is
bookkeeping and administrative I have a
varied background I work for so many
businesses there isn't enough time here
to
list them all uh
I like Judiciary I believe in the law
I'm very big on the law
and I feel it applies to everybody I
don't care what your place is in life if
you are rich you are poor we all obey
the laws I also am very strong in the
Constitution I am very strong in the
right to know us and the only reason I
am here the first term in this term is
to serve the peer and the people period
that's it I serve nobody else
I'm looking forward to this term uh one
thing I do and I've always done
sometimes I don't say too much I am
right now but I don't say too much I
love listening to other people I don't
care which side of the aisle they're on
I love listening I learn from everybody
I might think I know everything and I
listen to somebody else and oh yeah I
would never think of that and so I think
we all each and every one of us need to
listen to each other
whether we agree or don't agree thank
you
representative Perez
hi I'm Christine Perez I am from
Londonderry and I did shower this
morning you noticed it but
um I am a retired intensive care nurse I
worked for 42 years I retired from the
recovery room because all intensive care
nurses die in The Recovery Room so
um I am a huge proponent of
um the um
Second Amendment as well last year I
started the second amendment
preservation Coalition in Londonderry
and worked with protect New Hampshire to
try to make sure that our rights in the
Second Amendment were not taken away
from us I'm a huge proponent of the
Constitution as written
um I believe in the constitution of New
Hampshire as written not that I agree
with everything that's in it but um
I believe that it was written for a
reason as our Constitution of the United
States I'm a huge proponent of parental
rights
I actually
um
got involved in doing this because I had
a group a huge group of parents that I
had spoken for at many many school board
meetings who encouraged me to do this
and um but I'm also a senior and only
been a senior community and they have
supported me in doing this I believe in
voter Integrity some of the things that
this was not my first choice but I see
it as a learning experience there's a
lot of things in here that I know I can
grow with the right to know is huge for
me I think it's um
it has some issues right now and also
privacy
um marriage abortion and assisted death
so
um not that I'm not interested in the
rest of the things but those things I
feel I have some knowledge about but I'm
I'm here I can't wait to learn and I
can't wait to get to know you all thank
you
thank you episode Perez
um representative Manos
thank you Mr chair my name is Zoe Manos
I'm from stratum which is down near Fort
Smith and I am an attorney
um I've been practicing law for about 30
years
I started my career by doing neglect and
abuse cases in Massachusetts uh Lawrence
and Haverhill and then I did neglect and
abuse cases in Portsmouth so I've seen
um I've seen our child welfare system
and now I practice uh family law so
that's my background I
um I'm particularly pleased to be here I
love the law
um respect it and love it
um and I am strongly pro-choice and so
those are issues that are particularly
important to me and
um and I I definitely am pleased to be
here and look forward to working with
everyone thank you great thank you
Representatives
um
representative Tripp sir my name is
Richard Tripp I'm uh from Derry
uh seems like I fit into the mold here
because uh I was surprised when I found
out I was unjudiciary
but uh I'm uh
grew up in uh
municipal government
uh I was uh
on uh
planning board
uh Sun conservation
I was on the Town Council
and I'm currently on the zoning board so
you might understand my interest in land
use
so uh this is my third term
I uh
sat on Municipal County land use
you know people used to ask me they go
what do you do up in Concord and I says
well I try and keep the state out of the
nose the state's nose out of the town's
business you know
so anyhow uh
I uh am a retired engineer so I spent
eight years in an 82. uh that was
interesting
I don't know who's happier when I get
out me or the Navy but uh uh the uh
anyhow
uh if I have a strength it's uh I'm a
curious person and uh if I'm assigned to
any subcommittees or whatever I you know
I will work very hard because I like to
learn thank you
thank you representative representative
Horgan
so I'm representative Timothy Horrigan
I'm
I'm actually a legacy representative my
late father served uh back in the 70s
and I often wonder if my name tag if my
name played is uh looks a little older
than some of the others have so often
wonder whether his was stored in some
closet and they dug it out when I came
back and so I swept in office in in
2008 along with my fellow Columbia
alumnus uh Barack Obama who I knew a
little bit but I didn't pay much
attention to him he uh he studied a lot
more than I did and got into the Harvard
Law School and he's president but I'm
but I'm here so that's nothing to be
ashamed of I've been just starting my
eighth term it's my sixth term of this
committee before that I was um I started
on an election law which
back before I was a rep I'm spending a
lot of time agitating for democracy and
the rule of law and also an issue which
never seems to go away which is the
Integrity of the of the voting machines
and
um
and then actually it's appropriate today
we have a bill about a granny D-Day so
she was a local uh she's a local
activist she's famous Nation invited
worldwide so urge you all to vote for
that bill when it comes to the house
stuff
um then in between election law and this
committee is on something called the
petitions and redress committee which
was mostly aggrieved
family law
family law lit against most of whom
I mean you could probably
most it's quite easy especially for
Resident per se to get yourself into a
bit of a bit of a pickle particularly if
you're on the wrong side of your lawn in
many cases you were these were men
Sometimes women who weren't paying to
child support or not doing other other
things and it's a terrible situation for
them but to some extent uh
someone said there's not much you can do
about us so the committee didn't do much
about that was when I first learned the
existence of a representative Lynn back
then I think you were still a superior
court judge and uh you were you're very
you're very nice guy you're an excellent
choice to share but I've seen some
videos where like you know if you're if
you're actually on creating someone in
the courtroom you were very firm with
them so and I I I I understand 100 of
why you had to do that sometimes and uh
you mentioned your constitutional
amendment my first term I tried to
eliminate the age limit for for judges
and um
that felt just a little shorter we
needed 240 votes to pass it through the
house we got uh 200 vote 40 votes
against it so uh it's a I don't know if
the numbers have changed much than that
but good luck with that one and um
in terms of my uh career outside the
legislature as a writer and a computer
consultant for while I was working in a
group that's available in the technical
standards for the the metaverse which
you occasionally hear about but probably
not much of you have actually uh visited
it and um
and for a while it's also working for
the uh
the educational testing firm
um which at that time is no measure
progress I think they've been bought up
by somebody so if any of you are in
school in the early 2000s or at
Children's school so my my apologies uh
the testing was a little bit uh I don't
necessarily agree with everything they
did with the testing but that's a matter
of the education committee so um
Church of my legislative priorities I'm
very strongly in favor of uh
individual freedom in terms of rule of
law democracy um on the other hand I am
uh I mean certainly I believe in the
Second Amendment as written but I'm not
sure but I'm I think that uh I think
gunned Common Sense gun safety policies
are not unconstitutional and that's uh
probably what the Supreme Court has
generally helped and um
so it should be
should be a should be an interesting uh
interesting session I'm glad to be back
because a number of us uh were here last
term either weren't reelected and I won
my primary by just four votes and had to
go to a recount and or
some of them have been moved to other
committees so like there's like a lot of
uh a lot of new faces here which I guess
is uh I guess it's good and also I'm
from Durham and a majority of the Durham
delegation has I think almost the whole
time we've been in judiciary we've had a
majority of the Durham delegation on the
Judiciary Committee so that's just sort
of one of these strange little
traditions we have here at the house so
uh because it's also President Kennedy
who haven't met yet but you'll meet him
soon enough and he's so thanks
thank you representative representative
Wallace he was had a medical appointment
this morning
um I wonder if you could just tell us a
little bit about your background yes
thank you thank you thank you um
apologize for my tiredness fellow
committee members um
my name is representative Scott Wallace
I'm from the town of Danville this is my
fourth term uh previous three terms
around criminal justice committee last
term as the clerk
um I too a new appointee to this
committee and happy to be working with
all of you
um my background is distinctly different
than most human retired mechanic and
helicopter pilot so I'm looking to
learning uh some of the new the subject
matters that I haven't been exposed to
yet along with all of you and uh
we'll keep this very professional and
get the ball moving down the field and
get our work done as we as we should
thank you thank you very much
all right um
so you know what I uh what I'd like to
do next if I could is
um uh we have in the audience Richard
head who uh is from the judicial branch
and I wonder Richard if you could just
introduce yourself I suspect that we
will be seeing him
with some regularity
um uh during the during the year and so
it's if you can take a minute to
introduce yourself and tell us what you
what you you know likely will be here
and what you will be uh uh what you will
be telling us not not at any particular
bill but just sort of generally the
information that you usually would be
providing sure um thank you Mr chairman
thank you members of the committee my
name is Richard head I have several
titles with the judicial branch the one
that relates here is the government
Affairs coordinator so I I manage all
the legislative issues that apply to the
judicial branch
and it turns out probably about half the
bills that are presented in some way
interact with the judicial branch either
uh have a fiscal impact up on the branch
which is what you'll hear a lot from me
um they require some modifications to
our processes so I talk about those my
goal in terms of my presentations to any
committee is to provide sort of the
perspective of the judicial branch in
terms of how bills interact with the
branch
um in terms of my background I've been
in this position for uh three years now
um my practice was divided about half of
my uh years of practice was in uh in
private practice in New Hampshire and
about half of it was at the Attorney
General's office
at the Attorney General's office and in
private practice the vast majority of
that has been uh on the Civil side of
the fence so at the AG's office I was
the consumer bureau chief I was the
environmental bureau chief and then I
oversaw the Civil side of the office for
a while
um
you know I had in my practice I had the
opportunity to appear in front of
Justice Lynn both when he was a spirit
court judge and as a Supreme Court Judge
Justice uh you're very lucky he's a very
fair uh uh individual he fortunately
listens uh and is a great listener
didn't always rule my way but I never
hold that against anyone I recognize
that there are differing views and I
think during the course of my
presentations we will probably have
differing views but my goal is always to
try to present factual information
and information that that reflects how
the judicial branch is impacted by
legislation that appears before you I'm
always available to answer questions I
encourage anyone to call me anytime if
you have questions or if you see me in
the hallways feel free always to stop me
and ask me anything about
things of interest to you A lot of the
times I say I don't know I have to get
back to you and I try to get back to you
whenever I I don't know the answer to a
question
but thank you Mr chairman thank you for
letting me introduce myself thank you
and you know could I uh just uh sort of
a as a matter of maybe an informational
matter
um am I correct Mr head that
it will often be the case that the
judicial branch on some particular issue
will be will be coming to provide us
simply with information not without sort
of taking a position on whether they
think the legislation is good or not
um even even if the even if sort of you
know internally some members of the of
the judicial branch may think it is
either a good idea or a bad idea
based upon my experience often if uh
unless it's something that's you know
really would have a tremendously
detrimental effect on the Judiciary the
court is likely to say this is a policy
matter for the legislature and we don't
here here's what you should know but we
don't take a position am I am I is that
still basically what the court does it's
a fair point so in terms of of the the
bills that impact us we do try not to
get involved in the underlying policy
I've had some some conversations with
representative Smith
if I can I try to say that we support or
oppose a particular aspect of a bill but
there are frequently instances in which
we don't have a position on the policy
of the bill you may hear me testify in a
way that sounds positive or sounds
negative because
oftentimes a bill which has a a policy
purpose we don't have a position on will
have a significant impact on the
judicial branch so I would be testifying
not about the policy itself but to try
to it's sort of how
a bill will have an impact on resources
within the branch so if a particular
Bill were to pass so for example if it
required us to hear certain types of
cases in 30 days okay we can we can do
that but then the impact on that is
going to be we can't hear other cases
that are discretionary because we have
to move cases up in this session they're
probably 15 bills
that put in deadlines in terms of when
the court is supposed to hear things and
that is is a policy position and what my
presentation would typically be is you
know there are certain number of cases
that fall in that category we have to
move those cases forward so as a result
you know we can only hear so many cases
in a day so other cases that we do not
have a statutory or constitutional
mandate to hear quickly are going to get
pushed and we've seen that and we see
that with bills so that's the type of
information I might provide and it may
sound negative I don't mean it to sound
negative it is simply it has an impact
on the on the court system and I try to
explain how that impacts operations
within the system
thank you Mr Andrew any any
representative have any questions for Mr
head as I say we're not here on any
particular bills but if you have any
sort of general questions uh
this is the time
great thank you very much also I learned
from representative Smith that any
exhibits I hand out will have three
holes punched in
thank you that's a great idea an
excellent just also one one other thing
I have to go to uh house criminal
justice you'll see frequently when I'm
here I'm going back and forth because
unfortunately they're meeting at the
same time
thank you okay thank you yes thank you
if I could just say that I'm delighted
that I've had so much influence on on
Miss Mr head I'd like him to have more
influence on us because he has knowledge
and experience that many of us don't
have and the implications of something
that looks quite innocent to us might
not in fact be innocent and that's why
I push you sometimes and I know it makes
you uncomfortable but I believe it's in
the best interests of the citizens of
the state so thank you for being patient
thank you Mr head
um I I know that there are a number of
other people in the audience I'm
wondering are there any are there any
other people here that rep that are
represent sort of state agencies of one
kind or another that may be appearing
before us with some regularity if if
that's the case and you'd like to
introduce yourself uh please do so
all right uh seeing none uh then let me
um let me just sort of turn to some
Logistics uh
um
as you know I sent out a memo and um
originally my memo said we're gonna meet
on Wednesday mornings hear the bills and
then the following Wednesday we'll hear
the we'll hear more bills and on
Wednesday mornings and we'll have
executive sessions in the afternoon
representative Smith very wisely quickly
educated me that that probably is not
likely to work given uh the extent of
given our workload basically
so it's more likely that at least in the
beginning we're going to be hearing
bills
um for full days on Wednesdays and it it
seems from from
the schedule that was that was used last
year and actually that was the second
year which is generally less less busy
than the first last year the Judiciary
Committee tended to generally met two
days a week I think it's very likely
that we're going to have to do that also
and so my my inclination would be that
we would meet on Wednesdays and
Thursdays
Thursdays it will generally be the day
when that when the Full House meets not
every week but so we're obviously on a
week when the Full House is meeting we
can't meet on Thursdays but on other
days on other weeks that would be my
inclination is to have us meet on
Thursdays uh
um but I'm you know again if if uh if
somebody tells me Thursday is absolutely
the worst possible day and we have some
as a really you know I'm I'm open but
I'm not bear in mind this room is used
on Tuesdays by children and family and
on Fridays by state federal relations so
that basically means that Monday and
Thursday is the and I think Thursday is
probably the one that makes the most
sense
uh Mr human yes
um what time do you envision that we'll
meet on Wednesdays
starting time yeah I would generally say
nine o'clock
um
other other questions
yes representative Alexander thank you
Mr chair so typically in the past um and
I'm going to defer to you but the chair
um grouped together similar bills for
public hearings was that your intention
just so we could allow the public maybe
one day if say they're interested in
um you know any bills uh regarding
abortion like they could come in that
day and so they don't have to come
multiple days was that still your
intention yes absolutely so I'm um I
I've as of yesterday I believe I I when
I or not yesterday Monday I'm sorry
um uh we had there were 29 bills that I
was given copies of now I understand
it's grown since then uh it's third up
to 38.
um but what I saw as I went through them
is I I came to sort of three groupings
one was there's a bunch of landlord
Senate bills there's a bunch of right to
know bills and there's a bunch of
abortion bills so I do I agree
completely uh representative Alexander
that we should we should group those
together and hear them
um you know hear them all on the same
day you should know that I have already
scheduled for next week I've scheduled
hearings on eight bills and I violated
that and because I those those seem like
the ones that were the most likely to be
um
for lack of a better term non-com in my
judgment non-controversial either they
were you know they seemed to me to be
either very good or very bad
um but but uh that and that may that may
not be that right and I'm not going to
tell you and that may not be you may all
have a completely different view on that
you may say all the ones that I thought
were bad they're good and all the ones
that I thought were good were bad but I
would say that I I among those I did
include one bill
um that dealt with landlord tenant it
was actually my the bill I talked about
before about the termination of tenancy
at the end of a lease but that's the
only one I so
um with that kind of exception I I would
plan to schedule
um our hearing or you know to group
bills by subject matter
um and I think probably
um
for the abortion my inclination is that
for the abortion bills we should
probably try to do that in the house
because we'll have uh we'll have you
know a number a number of witnesses
representative you mean in reps hole
that's all yes and I think that's
probably a wise a wise decision and
again group them together so that
citizens who are interested Advocates
um legislators know they're there for
the
the Long Haul
um I I wonder
um
Mr chair if
um you and the staff support that you
have could double check to see if you in
fact have any early bills because those
bills will have to be heard first and
you should have the Chairman's copy by
now of bills and if you don't you might
want to check with the clerk's office
I also would ask I think on behalf of
all of us that you don't schedule these
from week to week in that meaning that
if you can schedule
15 bills for the next two two weeks or
three weeks or whatever it happens to be
give us as much notice as possible and
give the public as much notice as
possible that you're going to be hearing
the right to know bills on such and such
a date okay
that's a girl I had not thought that's a
very good idea and I I mean that does
that make that makes sense to everybody
all right well that's what I'll do
absolutely thank you absolutely
okay
um oh yes well I'm sorry yes
representative Morgan well this is uh I
mean I guess we'll know more the answer
to this when we start actually having
hearings scheduled when the calendar
comes out on Thursday but they've
revived the remote sign in from last
session where you can say you're either
four or against a bill and you can
submit preferably an Adobe PDF format a
copy of your of your testimony and last
year you could then the public anybody a
member or any member of the public could
see a list of who signed in for against
and if they submit a testimony could
download their testimony and now that um
at least so far is not being done this
year so how how will we be able to
what's your mechanism exists so we can
see the uh
we can see the files they submit a
testimony the names of who signed in for
against and also a related question is
how
how should Witnesses uh
submit their testimony does it is email
testimony gonna be including the bill
files in this committee or do you have
to do a printed file or submitted
through the portal so I don't
I'm part of what are their choices in
terms of submitting written testimony to
us
so I um
I don't I'm not sure that it has been
finalized yet to Beyond to be honest
with you but those are all good
questions we'll we'll figure out the
we'll find the answers to that
um uh yeah so I I mean stay tuned I
guess I will have I will have thank you
oh maybe representative kuchoff hasn't
answered so yesterday I attended the
clerks training and clerk Smith let us
know that it will be at the discretion
of the chair whether or not to accept a
particular piece of email testimony but
as a general rule
we should be utilizing the portal which
you can actually currently view for
every Bill what is submitted so it is
actually up and running
for for people to use but it was just
getting really hard to track via email
you know sometimes people will use a
computer service that you know like a
jot form that's sending out thousands
from many people and it was just really
difficult to track how many people were
for or against and and using the online
just makes it much easier
okay so that's so that has been decided
okay yes uh representative thank you Mr
chair I have a question on the housing
bills I noticed well yesterday that um
housing bills were still in the um
Judiciary post-judiciary Silo but I
understand that there's a special
housing committee and was wondering you
know are the lean on tenants Bill going
to be here are they going to be heard in
uh the special housing committee
my understanding is that we're coming
here but representative Alexander maybe
you you may have more information on
that than I do
um I thank you Mr chair I have a feeling
that we're going to hear those here but
I also know there are a number of
members of this committee that also sit
on the special committee and I think
that
um if needed we should consult with that
special committee on certain bills
especially if we're undecided on
something
um maybe bring them in and have joint
committees or whatever whatever you
whatever the discretion of the chair is
um especially on like the bigger like
the bigger more intensive bills maybe
like Land review DACA something like
that like bring in their expertise as
well sure that makes sense to me that
makes sense
yes representative Manos
thank you Mr chair
um
so I was just wondering in general so
for example your bill to uh terminate
tenancy at the expiration of the tenancy
or the lease term
how would we have the citation to the
New Hampshire Supreme Court decision so
that we could kind of consider that and
put that sure you know what I I don't I
I don't have it off the top of my head
but I you know when I testify to
introducing the bill I will have that I
I have it at home I just didn't bring it
with me but uh okay it's um I wish I
could remember the name of it I think
it's decided
I said I said mid 80s I might be I may
be wrong on that it might be it might be
mid 90s but anyway I do remember uh
but in general
um I know we have a researcher
um is that a question we could ask the
researcher
there are 20 of us and
um we can generate a lot of questions
and the procedure in the house for
obvious reasons is if you have a
question of the researcher you go
through the chair of the committee and
the chair is the person who can ask the
researcher to do all kinds of things
including uh for example side by side
comparisons of different bills and and
other issues however there are other
resources the um office of legislative
Services doesn't only draft bills they
also have a whole section where there
are people there
very happy to answer questions that you
might have so you go down there first
floor of the um of the state house and
those uh people are on the if you're
facing where the OLS is there on the far
right and you can just go in and say I
have a question can you help me research
this and they will do that for you so
there are other possible the third place
to go is
um there are
um they're lobbyists they're Advocates
some wear orange badges particularly if
they're paid but not only if they're
paid others don't and one of the things
that you will learn
and I hope I offend No One by saying
this some of those
people are incredibly helpful they will
be absolutely accurate and they won't
spin and they'll say this is what this
is there then they might even tell you
the other side might think that and some
of those people are not completely
accurate and by talking to your
colleagues and by your own experience
you'll learn who you can rely on it's
something we do more in this state than
in many other states because we do not
have
um
the overly generous staff support and so
we have to look elsewhere
so so in answer to your you know your
specific way I mean I will
um uh in fact I can you know I will when
I go home I can uh I'll get the case and
I can just I can email you the name of
the case it's uh
um I don't want to have where I already
have the information there's no sense in
asking the researcher to look it up
again
um
all right
um so
um
so as I say our usual meeting day will
be Wednesday I will generally start at 9
00 a.m uh we'll we'll
um I'm sure we're gonna need to use to
to be hearing bills on Thursdays also so
I think you can kind of generally plan
that we'll be sitting on Wednesdays and
Thursdays
um with the exception of days when the
Full House is meeting on Thursdays
um I would ask you um to please be here
and be on time obviously if there's you
know if there you have medical
appointments or other things like that
you know that there's going to cause you
to be late we understand but if but
barring something really important to
ask you to be here and be on time and if
for some reason you can't be here
please either let me know or let the
ranking member know so that we can
arrange to have a substitute for you
as I understand the rules we don't need
to have a quorum to hold hearings but
obviously we do need to we do need to
have a quorum for executive sessions and
so it's particularly important uh in
executive sessions that we that
everybody be here unless there's really
a very strong reason not to be here and
if you can't be here let you know either
me know if you're if uh if you're in the
majority majority party or let the
ranking member know if you are in the
minority party so that substitutes can
be arranged
I'm sorry that's right 24 hours
and also you have to actually be absent
from the state house so you're not
allowed to be
get a substitute but then still be in
the State House doing something else so
if I understand the rules correctly no
that's right if you're gone you're gone
for the day that's that's right as I
understand
um the other thing I'd like to do is I
really would like to encourage all
members to be active
um uh you know please uh we if you have
questions and you're interested in
something don't don't hesitate to ask
I'll uh I'll you know I'm not inclined
to uh in any way to prevent any members
of this committee from asking questions
where they have questions
um
I would I would say please let's make
sure that we treat all people that come
before the committee and treat each
other with respect and dignity at all
times uh
um that's what everybody has the right
to uh you know the right to uh insist
upon and I and I certainly would would
insist upon it and I would I would say
you know if you're uh at the time for my
view is the time for us to debate is
during executive sessions that's when
it's appropriate to have a debate it's
not a good idea to have a debate with a
witness in other words you if you have
questions certainly ask the questions
and if you if the if you're not
satisfied with you know an answer or the
answer is incomplete don't hesitate to
ask for a follow-up question but you
know I that it it can't turn into a
debate with the witness that's just very
unproductive
um and we'll we'll end up wasting a lot
of time so I'd encourage that you know
please please don't do that
um
other things that I
generally
um and I've talked with representative
Smith about this and I believe she
agrees but if I'm if I'm if I'm wrong
I'm sure she'll correct me the the
procedure we'll follow is the bill
sponsor will testify first
um then my practice would be that if
there are other Representatives or
Senators here who have somewhere else to
go and you know that they they have
another hearing that they need to attend
to or either on another bill or they're
or they have other committee work then I
would I would give them preference to
testify next but if they don't
um then I would then I would my
inclination would be not to give them a
preference and just to go with people
who have who may have you know other uh
other uh places to be themselves uh
particularly if uh if some if they're
people that are that are
for lack of a better term I would I
would refer to them as sort of experts
that maybe are being paid from by one by
one person or another
um uh I would tend to to go with those
people next and then generally members
of the public but I'm you know that's
that would be generally my inclination
I'm open to if people have different
views on that I'm open to uh to hearing
those
all right
um
again as I said I
my inclination is to let everybody say
their peace I I would prefer not to have
time limits but I'm I'm very concerned
that with many bills it'll be necessary
to have time limits and so I will try to
uh you know enforce the time limits
fairly if we say three minutes maybe the
sponsor gets five minutes and everybody
else gets three or something like that
and I will I will enforce that across
the board whether somebody's testifying
in support of a bill or uh opposed to a
bill and that will hopefully keep us
generally on time uh so that we get
um we get through our work
um
yes representative
thank you Mr Speaker I have a question
um I sponsored a bill so I will have to
um
present that bill at some point
um if it doesn't interfere with any of
our meetings that's great but if it will
interfere how exactly is that handled
yeah you can be no you will be excused
to to testify on that to testify on that
bill I've got you know I've got the same
situation I'm going to have uh I'm going
to have some bills in other committees
that I'll have to excuse myself so we
should just let you know ahead just let
me know yeah just let me know and I have
one more question and it's just a
are we allowed to have a drink in here
are we allowed to have food in here I
just wanted to know what that was like I
brought in almonds because I didn't have
a chance to have breakfast this morning
and I'm sneaking them over here and
popping them in my mouth but I want to
know what's allowed ready
sneaky my understanding of the practice
has been and this was the way it was on
finance last year and I think it was the
way I was on this committee you can
bring in water okay that's kind of it no
no uh you know no other drinks and no
other food okay
containments no no Brandy containers
okay well I don't know Brandy contains
but
um again it's just a question of being
respectful to the people who are here
um if we're having an informal meeting
whether a caucus or just a discussion
you know that's different but when we're
conducting hearings when we're voting
um it's just a sign of respect yes that
was that that was what we were told
initially I just wanted to clarify that
that too was the truth now thank you but
speaking of of that if I could add at
this time if you go into the office I
don't know if the draws have been newly
labeled yet
um it that will have to be done perhaps
by Karen or somebody else you each have
your own draw you will also my children
my grandchildren say I don't pronounce
that word correctly but you know what I
mean
um
um you will also find a a coffee machine
in the office
and it's all equipped the only thing is
I I didn't find those little
milk things other than that I mean
there's coffee and sugar and it's
available for all Judiciary Committee
members there is a note there that says
if you just can't resist and you're not
a Judiciary member please leave a dollar
uh
uh but so that at any point you know
that you might have to leave to
um to make a phone call or you just
can't stand it anymore and you've got to
stretch your legs and you want a cup of
coffee that's in the committee office
um so the the other uh thing I want to
talk about is uh basically when when
once we get to Executive sessions and
we've we're we're voting on bills
um uh then I will uh try to disperse
evenly uh you know if if we're if we're
not divided if it's going to be if if
we're unanimous or you're nearly
unanimous I will try to disperse evenly
among all the members of the committee
responsibility for writing uh reports on
the bill reports on the bills if we're
divided
um then I again will will uh we'll try
to fairly distribute among the the
majority party responsibility for
writing the bills and I'm sure
representative Smith will do the same
for uh the minority and I just I I'm
suspecting here I I think it's probably
accurate that there may be a number of
matters in which the committee has no
recommendation because we're equally
divided I suspect that that may that
that may happen
um uh I'd like to word it another way if
I could Mr chair I suspect that in the
majority of bills that come before this
committee we are either unanimous or
nearly unanimous because that is in all
my experience that has been true there
are a few areas
where that is not likely to happen but I
think that will be the minority of of
bills
um and I think that the tone that you're
setting starting right now about
evenness and fairness and inclusion for
everyone is going to help remind all of
us that while there are a few issues
that we feel so strongly about and that
for one reason or another those issues
tend to
parallel party division
I think that there we will disagree and
there will be 10 10 votes but I think
overwhelmingly it will not be the case
and perhaps others don't agree with me
but I think I I see my good colleague
from Ghost Town I think does agree with
me that that's likely to be the case
I hope I hope I hope you're right I do
we've we've Mr chair we've had a great
history of working together and kind of
amending bills or deciding not to amend
bills
um and I I just would like to Echo uh my
friend representative Smith because we
have had some great experience in this
committee even though there have been
some pretty heavy subjects as well great
thank you
um
so the the last thing I would uh talk
about and then I'll open it up if
anybody else has anything they want to
say
um it's just
um uh our demeanor at hearings um I
mentioned before you know it's it's not
it's generally not productive to try to
have a debate with a witness
um uh the other thing I would suggest is
it's really important I think that in in
the interest of making sure that
everyone feels you know that that
they're
um that they have an opportunity to be
heard that we
um you know know uh
for lack of a better term no you know
rolling rolling your eyes or raising
eyebrows or that kind of thing I mean
it's just it just sends the wrong
message to people who are testifying if
you you may you may think that somebody
is completely all wet and you know out
out to lunch but uh
you know we we we can discuss that in an
executive session and you can have
you'll have every opportunity to to say
what you think but I think it's very
very important that people have a sense
that they've that they've been heard by
people who are interested in what they
have to say and you know our our fairly
evaluating what they have to say
um that's um
oh I'm sorry representative uh Turner
yeah yeah thank you Mr chair a real real
specific question um do you have a
preferred way if we want to be
recognized as the conversations going
around to to ask for that
you know if you just if you just sort of
raise your hand
um you know you know the other thing I
would say is I know and this is when I
was on finance this got to be awkward to
some extent so
um my general preference would be but if
you know again I stand to be corrected
if somebody thinks this could be a
problem
if if you're if let's say you have a
question you raise your hand and I say
representative turd you know you have
questions
generally
by
I I'm content to have you ask your
question and ask a follow-up if you have
a follow-up without having to say can I
ask a follow-up it's just seeing because
I know in finance that got to be very it
got to be very awkward of you know going
there was more conversation between the
chair and the uh and the member about
whether they could ask a follow-up then
it would be a lot simpler to just ask to
follow now if it gets you know if if it
if if one follow-up or two follow-up
starts to look like it's going to be 10
follow-ups I might interrupt and say
well wait a minute you know there are
other people with their hands raised who
want to ask questions
um but generally uh you know I I would
prefer to have members be able to ask
their questions and and and if if you
know if the answer
um if if the if the question isn't
answered to your satisfaction to be able
to ask a follow-up without having to say
can I can I ask a follow-up Mr chair
that makes a lot of sense and if I could
also just point out
um you don't need to wave your hand if
you just kind of signal the clerk
the um
the deputy the vice chair
and the ranking member will be generally
looking around and so we can then say to
the chair
um uh representative Paris has a
question and and he'll keep a list you
know in order of what people see and
then you just wait your turn and that
way it can all be done and give the
illusion at least that we're very very
you know
a well-oiled machine yes Mr here yes
it's a quick question do you have a
policy on um whether we can have like
laptops here or
um
yeah I I don't I I don't have a problem
with that
um I guess the only thing I would say is
this it um
it's I think I think it's really
important that if you have a laptop if
you want to bring a laptop I don't have
a problem with that but what I think
would really be a bad look so to speak
from the public is if you're just
you know like this and and the you know
and it doesn't appear that you're paying
attention to the witness so if you want
to bring a laptop that's fine but
um you know when when the witness is
testifying I think we need we all need
to be paying attention to what the
witness is saying thank you
yes
I just want to mention that
if there's a lot of Smiths people have a
tendency to make sure they have the
correct Smiths I there are only two
Perez's and I believe that
um you have a tendency to think that
well that there's only one Perez I have
received mail that has not been for me
but has been for Maria Perez so please I
ask you just remember I'm Christine with
a K Perez okay good point
so you know what uh representative
Horrigan you you raised a
you raised a question and I I want to uh
I wanna follow up on because I think it
was it was uh an important one and I I'm
going to ask uh representative Smith for
guidance on this I
um
my understanding is that frequently it
will happen that a witness will come to
testify you know orally but we'll also
Present written testimony that uh my
inclination unless somebody tells me we
shouldn't my inclination is that's
perfectly fine they can present their
written testimony that will become part
of the record and uh and and so I assume
that
that you what you were asking about
before was not to suggest that there's
any limitation on that no not at all so
okay I think that's a very good practice
if they write out what they're going to
have to say hopefully it won't be too
long but uh yeah but yeah sure well I
think in some sense that you know if
particularly if we're gonna if we're
going to be limiting testimony for oral
testimony to three minutes or whatever
it and somebody has more they want to
say they can say it in written testimony
so
all right
um
anything else of course in my most
obstetris how do I say that
strappers I think
um mood
um when people read word for word
testimony that they have written
my inclination when I'm feeling I'll
just say rude I don't have to use a word
I can't pronounce is to say all of us
read and we will all read your testimony
why don't you tell us
what you think are the most important
points and that might not be very fair
because some people are very nervous
when they appear before us and they
can't they couldn't do it without
reading and
um and I don't like not to be fair but I
do get impatient when somebody has 10
pages that they're going to read to us
word for word right representative yes I
I agree with that there are some
instances members of the public it's
good for them to have their crib notes
if you will to keep them on subject
matter and on a good Tempo however again
a 10-page report from some subject
matter expert we can all digest that at
our own Leisure and not burn a
committee's Time unnecessarily
right yeah I've I've sort of with you
representative Smith I I think that you
know that uh when I was still in the
court and people would occasionally do
that
um uh particularly at like at oral
argument at the Supreme Court it really
it was not very effective and I think
all of us were would get uh would get
frustrated at that but I but I do
understand I think your point is well
taken some people are
um you know I've particularly if we had
Pro Se people in front of the court
um they are nervous and that it's
sometimes you just sort of tolerate that
that's uh but it's but it does it can be
sort of nerve-wracking I agree and we
will have people with obvious
disabilities and we can be sensitive to
that but we will have people whose
disabilities aren't obvious and we have
to you know
that we have to accommodate that it's
hard it's hard it's this is not easy
stuff and that's part of what I mean by
saying you've learned something new
every day and one of the things you
learn
um some of you might uh
some of you have been here before uh
would be familiar with the name Alabama
Sarah Al and I
will be very good friends nobody
can understand how the two of us could
be very good friends
but we were and you will all learn that
you can be very good friends with
someone where you don't agree with them
on any issue that's before us
but the decent people or they you know
they like Opera that you do or they like
high tea or and just keep that in mind
as you meet
members on your side of the aisle and
members on the other side yeah it's uh
they're 400 of us and we're not actually
a cross-section of the state we know
that because there are many issues where
the public seems to feel one way but the
legislature feels another but just keep
that in mind about
and you open up your eyes to the
differences about stuff and the
similarities does that sound like a
violent play it's not it's not yes
representative and I like to add to that
we've all got to learn how to get along
I don't care if we're on one side of the
aisle or the other I worked for this guy
for over 20 years
he was on one side of the aisle and I
was on the other we never agreed but
what we did we never talked politics but
we had a great friendship there's so
many things he liked that I liked and
vice versa and I think we get to
sometimes stop looking at things that as
the person and not what they believe in
thank you well I I would Echo your your
view I and I to sort of personalize this
uh the love of my life my wife uh
um is a committed Democrat we uh we we
often uh we often uh I we are we often
say to each other that we when we go to
the polls we cancel each other out
because
so I think if uh if we can do that in a
marriage of oh 27 years uh I I think we
can do it here yes that's an observation
um you know last session
um
I found it very very awkward that when
folks were coming to testify they would
you know before speaking they would go
through all through the room to all of
us to pass out their testimony and it it
could have kind of wasted time so I
think that we should look at more
efficient ways to get that
um paper out paper to the machine back
on the end and pass it around yeah yeah
that's true but some of them some of
them will just walk right by people
nope okay no I I think that I think that
makes sense
other
yes certain
I just wanted to ask so
um when we're going to be meeting on
Wednesdays and Thursdays
um so during the when the house usually
meets on a Thursday would we also meet
on another day of that week probably not
probably not so that was that you know
what I'm I'm gonna
um I'm concerned about making sure that
we get our work done obviously so I mean
there may that may mean that they're
particularly as we have as as we get
closer to deadlines that may mean that
we're going to have some long days
um but um you know that's kind of
that's the way it is yes uh uh
representative Tripp
I've noticed that uh
there's a there's a lack of microphone
etiquette you know people uh they either
sit back like this or talk like this you
know uh I I assume that the the this is
being recorded
or the hearings will be recorded
I would ask that people speak into the
microphone so that when people are
watching it at home or we're reviewing
it so that we can hear what they're
saying you know and because like I said
I've I've seen several people here that
they're talking like this or uh that's
that's a very good point and I will try
to remember you know particularly with
at all I'd ask everyone here to make
sure you're talking to the microphone
but particularly with Witnesses I will
because you're right and we want to we
wanna this is being recorded and we want
to make sure that they're not that
they're being heard on the recording as
opposed to just you know sort of white
noise yeah yeah I'm sorry the other
thing is I believe if more than three of
the microphones are on that kind of
disables them
so when you're done speaking oh good
good point yeah okay good point
um with the microphones
um some people are even trying to listen
on YouTube while they're driving in
their car it says
so I did uh
yesterday and I know I forgot which
committee it was I was listening to and
actually they did a pretty good job with
the microphones but uh the worse
offender ironically was the rules
committee which is all the senior
leadership of the house and uh
well my own caucuses leader
representative Wilhelm was pretty
audible uh representative Simpson his
Deputy was very audible but like some of
the other people like they're just sort
of this murmur and I almost like drove
off the road trying to figure it trying
to get trying to like car radio loud
enough to hear them so like uh
well it's okay to listen just don't
watch the video which is pretty boring
anyway so um
actually and and also when I originally
raised my hand too on isn't Thursday
Thursday is also like a reporting
deadline every week to be in the next
week's uh session so although sometimes
we exact things and then don't vote on
on the full house until like
you know two or three weeks later it was
yeah
thanks
um anything else anything else yes
representative Staples yeah especially
during votes in executive sessions
um I've seen in the past from Zoom
review that some people didn't have
their microphones on
and so you're trying to figure out how
that's going to work in the final count
so if everybody's up close to the mic
and has the mic on for the votes that
helps the public understand what's going
on the other item I wanted to mention is
other committees
I've seen where a testimony will begin
and they'll split
the written testimony in half one on
this table one on the other table and
then we just pass them all up seems to
be a pretty efficient way instead of a
lot of moving around or one table only
all around yeah I think that makes sense
that makes a lot of sense I agree thank
you
all right right
other questions comments
yes I thought it was interesting that uh
representative Smith uh likes to have
the paper punched
is because I keep my bills
in a binder that keeps them
in order I put them in an order and then
I put all the testimony behind
and some people like to have an
individual file for each bill
works for them if they're neater than I
am but for me I need them all
too so that's why I have I brought the
binder because I knew that the chair
would have bills for us today it did and
now I can put it see now I like page
numbers
uh getting getting testimony or
documentation that doesn't have page
numbers is uh
you and I were in charge it would be
it'd be chaos
all right um so you so just so that um
everyone knows I as I said I I scheduled
I believe about eight bills for hearing
for next Wednesday I'm gonna add to that
so we're probably gonna be here for a
full day on Wednesday and I'm also going
to schedule bills for uh for the
following day
um I think
my my plan would be if there if of the
bills we've got if there are enough
bills to fill up the two days of work
without without addressing the three
where the three areas where we have a
lot of bills that is abortion landlord
tenant and right to know I will probably
not schedule those bills in that first
two day period two-day period but if you
know if we can't if we don't have enough
bills then I may schedule but again I
will try to I will try to if I'm gonna
do uh in one of those areas I'll try to
do all the bills we have in that area
you have to get that in by noon today I
think I do have to get it in yeah yeah
so
yes
I just want to say I appreciate that
from a new person perspective let us get
our feet wet before we get really hit
hard right no exactly I think that I
think that makes sense for all of us
really to um to try to get those bills
out of the way first all right great um
anything else
all right well thanks thanks so much for
coming I look forward to working with
all of you
it's a motion to adjourn so moved do we
have a second
okay all those in favor
aye any opposed all right
[Music]